yellow and welcome to this video I am
junior 64 what's this reading this is
very low Renee Alonso Garcia ok I don't
know this person so let's see what he is
playing against my banco by
transposition we've gotten to the
decline banker with 93 and Bishop d7 hi
yeah this is a light which is very solid
for white but not very troublesome for
black yep I'm closing the position down
here on the queenside in a way that
white has trouble getting any headway in
the center bishop at night are
completely misplaced down b3 is a yeah
he just about gets there to be true I
don't have a ticket again unfortunately
sometimes you can technically exploit
the long diagonal battle and it doesn't
seem to be the case here but I'm
definitely happy with my position now
after him cancelling I have two good
options I can close it down immediately
with e 5 or i can play is 6 i'm not
totally sure what's better here I think
I'm going for the for the shutdown makes
the bishop on me to look quite silly if
it decides to not take I mean white can
take on insects however in this
situation I think I have good prospects
okay so he wants to bring the night to
d3 that that definitely makes sense
shooting for a form so I'm going to be
rooted this Bishop should be on c8
anyway a little bit uncomfortable is
that my knight on f6 has no good Square
to go tuned I would like to prepare 5
here of course so I'm trying to do this
he always has ever won but okay if I go
f5 you can go F for but this is still I
think the way to go I can actually play
Bishop age 6 ok now it's irrelevant he
opens up my position oh yeah his
position is not at all bad here scribe 6
and night will come to you five at least
I have one very good piece on e5 however
yeah exactly is going to try to trade it
let's see we just actually train a
tongue I thought it would be interesting
to delay this a little bit because here
i feel i'm reasonably well set up with
this Queen comes G hive
it's not really playing this very
ambitious Leah same okay maybe I should
have played Knight f6 to keep a little
bit more tension a little bit more
tension okay I don't want to trade
absolutely everything so let's go here
the techie form clock yeah so what I
have to watch out for is potentially
dance sacrifices on c5 for a couple of
pounds no not anymore now okay cougar
form looks like huh yeah maybe it's very
little anyway very little to do here
anyway if I would get the knight to e5
that wouldn't be all that bad but oh wow
wow all of a sudden is playing
ambitiously haha so 97 Bishop g4 what's
the deal
hmm that is indeed an issue
Jim 97 in Bishop g4 I have a hard time
to actually move hmm I can unite your
form trying to go to see three or 2d to
it this is also not that great what
about this one yeah maybe now therefore
i can go King it 76 and so on so he will
come over so probably have to go g5 man
can I had to check it's a bloody check I
forgot that it's a check
now that was stupid now we can simply
locate the whole thing in hi boo should
be 4i forgot about this for Bishop d1
but he also didn't didn't do anything
about it Saudi six it's not going to six
okay okay still cannot do much anyway to
do something here probably no time for a
shame
you can maybe just play d 6 but it's not
really great draw yeah but repetition
not much that I can do maybe I could
have gone to jail for one move earlier
somewhere here I don't know I don't know
hmm yeah it's fine for surprising that
that it was irritating me quite a bit
yeah I probably have to keep the tension
here a little bit anyway so let's switch
on the analysis you and have a look yeah
as his main goal here was to like hide
everything that moved once the position
opened up a little bit mmm well okay so
I've formed ok yeah here I wasn't
unhappy about things that looks
reasonably complicated yeah maybe maybe
I should have played a bit more
precisely somewhere yeah I mean temp
these trades trades a lot the engine
wants to play this and keep a little bit
more pieces on the board yeah this is
probably better I mean black is quite
quite clearly am a little bit ahead in
this position which is also confirmed by
the engine I've got the better bishop
however it's got some space it's
difficult to do something real with this
but he also has some dark squid
weaknesses probably this is better
keeping it a little bit more on the
ground I mean this is very very lame
yeah yeah maybe I should go form for the
other ending here I mean it's possible
that are not really getting anywhere
this ending is what the computer
suggests like this night you have six
but the problem is I mean you can
probably
i'm not mistaken but can this this this
this this age five and he just stays i
mean i mean the engine gives black how
the ponder how do you win this position
that's kind of impossible the only way
is some some kind of peace sacrifice and
I don't think that this will work yeah
it's difficult to make something a lot
out of this position this air wasn't too
unhappy about but then the unusually
five whoa yeah now I thought if voice is
really good and I mean good I have to
have to properly this looks wrong
somehow okay the computer is not
impressed I was thinking I could maybe
be worth in this position but maybe I'm
wrong about this maybe not yeah I mean
this is probably okay III is maybe
better I completely ignored that that
when I take now that this is a check on
h 5 so that he can come up to you three
and here i mean i was kind of trying to
do things but no it is very very equal
yeah not much to do sometimes games go
like that ok guys thanks for watching